as the novel coronavirus continues to
spread around the world
officials are turning to increasingly
extreme measures to slow it down
Ramin Ascencio is in China reporting on
a city quarantined in all trains and
planes out of that city halted deserted
streets telling the story of a country
on lockdown while we haven't gone that
far in the US officials here are
encouraging people to stay at home and
to cancel classes and public gatherings
but are we also heading towards mass
quarantines and would they even work
here to find out more we spoke to
Lawrence Boston he's a professor of
global health law at Georgetown
University
I think the start didn't be helpful to
define exactly what a quarantine is
quarantine is when you're not known to
be infected but you've been exposed to
somebody who is infected I'm so you say
you just shook hands with somebody that
had Copeland you don't necessarily have
it but we will quarantine you for the
longest period of incubation of the
disease and in this case that's 14 days
masked quarantine is when we guard entry
and exit from a city or a town and we
confine everybody within those borders
self quarantine or isolation is
completely different than mass
quarantine in the United States during
covered and we've seen the largest
federal quarantine in recent history
some of better vaccum is from Wuhan but
some have been people who were rescued
off of the Grand Princess just docked
now in Oakland and also Diamond Princess
and I of Japan and then we evacuated our
citizens back to the United States so we
haven't seen anything like that in
recent history we've only seen self
quarantine or isolation in the United
States and I can see this increasing
exponentially that people shelter in
place mostly in their apartments in
their homes that can be either voluntary
or it might be that you were ordered
by force of water but either way it
applies to individuals
that's what self quarantine or isolation
is and how does that compare to
something like social distancing social
distancing is quite different we use
social distancing irrespective of
whether you've been infected or exposed
to a disease at that stage we're onto
what public health people call
mitigation and all that means is that
we're trying to slow the spread of the
infection and so social distancing
measures are things like school closures
postponing or canceling large gatherings
of things like political rallies it's
just a measure we try to separate the
population so that they're not you know
really being exposed to one another or
not they're not you know mingling in
crowded spaces what we want to do is we
want to buy ourselves some time so
looking specifically at what happened
and Wuhan in your opinion does that look
to have been a successful quarantine and
maybe what metrics do you look at when
determining if it was in fact successful
you have to remember this was a mass
quarantine that affected 60 million
people it was unprecedented I was very
worried about it because it congregated
a lot of people together and grew on but
recently the World Health Organization
has praised China they've said that the
rest of the world should use the China
model I have grave doubts about that
because it's true that cases have gone
down in China but they've also gone down
in South Korea so I don't know that you
need those draconian measures but you
know let's even assume for the moment
that it was effective there's still a
big cost we all know about the economic
cost the stock markets are going down
supply chains are disrupted work
environments and workers are disrupted
but there are also enormous human rights
implications it's a balance we have to
balance public health with civil
liberties and you
people have asked me you know could we
have a mass quarantine or a lockdown in
the United States could we lock down in
New York City um and I think it's
inconceivable in the United States even
though we are seeing it in another
liberal democracy which is intially
Americans wouldn't accept a degree of
social control that was needed in China
or the intrusive surveillance we need to
be sensible
so what then should our overall goal be
here and I think this would be a good
opportunity to talk about what we mean
by flattening the curve what we need to
do is try it in true public health
measures we need to really ramp up our
diagnostic testing we also need to test
not patients but in random samples in
the community so that we can see what's
going on silently but below the radar as
I suspect we have a lot of silent
transmission going on we're gonna need
them to isolate people who are sick
quarantined those who've been exposed I
think we're gonna probably need to do
school closures and closures and
cancellations of public events those are
the kinds of things we need to do and if
we could do those kinds of social
distance and isolation keeping people
away from one another we would flatten
the curve in other words instead of
pieces going up up up up
we would bend it to flatten it out a bit
and that buys us time because no days
weeks matter it buys us time to actually
use our public health tools but it also
buys us time to develop effective
specific treatments and then ultimately
it buys us a little more time to get you
know what is the Holy Grail which is a
vaccine but that probably won't be for
another year to a year and a half in
your opinion is it still possible for us
in the United States to prevent a kind
of worst-case scenario with this
outbreak but I think if we rapidly do a
surge response
surge funding and do the kinds of
measures we've been talking about like
isolation social distancing
more testing contact tracing I think we
standard you know reasonable chance of
bringing you numbers down you do have
good public health agencies and we need
to use them with science-based
evidence-based approaches in a
proportion way thank you very much for
joining us today okay thank you
take care
[Music]